[Music]
my name is
power kind of flickered
and it has caused a lot of havocs on
some of our technology systems so pray
for all of our technology people who are
amazing by the way
but i guess i can see the stress on
their faces so we just need to make sure
that we just do a silent prayer for them
that
they will um continue
keeping going on you guys are awesome
okay a couple quick announcements um so
we are doing a welcome to the table uh
class for some of our new folks next
week uh it's gonna be in uh after the
service so if that's something you're
interested in please stick around um
we'll be uh pizza uh brett will be kind
of going over some uh so the mission the
vision the values where you possibly
could potentially plug in
or that's something you might be
interested in
so just kind of let us know there are
cards in the back as you walk out the
door um that's something you're really
interested in just put welcome to the
table let's see w t t on the card there
we go that's the acronym on the back of
the card and that will uh let's let us
know that you're interested
every couple of years so this is kind of
a unique spot because we're having to
land on the time where this is actually
occurring and haven't seen our own
backyard
so you're you guys don't have to travel
you don't worry about
um what's great about this and one
reason why we're talking about it is
because
obviously
you know we have queer people in the
movie audience and things like that but
all a lot of our allies have experienced
all right um with so that you all can
help be equipped if you guys ever attend
so you say anyway we would want you to
attend it's going to be in november it's
the first weekend in november it's a
thursday evening friday and saturday um
there are also cards on the very back of
that table um where you can take some of
these not just as a reminder for
yourself maybe it's something you may
not be able to obtain yourself for
whatever reason but maybe you know
somebody that could attend or they would
be a benefit for something like this so
you can take this as a reminder and
share it with them
with that being said
thankfully our technology people are
amazing i told you great thank you great
people
um
um this space
thank you for just us being able to have
time where we can come here
to just open up our hearts and minds
to where you want us to be tonight i
pray that you be with us through our
worship
during the message during communion and
that you speak to our hearts in christ i
pray amen
guys stand with us and this is what
we're gonna do because it's been a
little dicey on the whole sound system
electricity thing
if it cuts out we're just going to keep
on rolling okay
so you guys are an extension of the band
tonight we need you now more than ever
before
so none of this just standing and
observing all right tonight you don't
get that pass you have to sing out
otherwise it will just be a very
quiet kumbaya session
at least after the kids go to kids
ministry it would be
all right
let's go ahead and get started noelle's
going to need this first song
[Music]
it's time to sing your song again
whatever may
pass and whatever lies before me
let me be singing with
[Music]
worship his
holy name
sing like never before
oh my
soul
worship your own
[Music]
your name is great and your heart is
kind for all your goodness i will keep
on singing
ten thousand reasons for my heart to
find bless the lord o my soul
[Music]
like never before
oh my
[Music]
is
day
when my strength is failing
the end draws near and my time has come
still my soul will sing your praise on
ending
ten thousand years
bless the lord
[Music]
i'll worship
is
[Music]
yeah
thank you guys yeah we can clap
all right you guys kids are dismissed to
their classrooms thanks so much for
worshiping with us and we're going to
keep on rolling here um
we're going to sing a song it's called
oceans and and you've probably heard it
before
but one of the things in the message of
this song that's been speaking to me
this week um adam and i were talking
earlier and i was just sharing with him
about uh
how
sometimes putting yourself out there
um requires so much bravery and it would
be easier to kind of
run away than to face the vulnerable
moments in our life it'd be easier to
never take the chance to never take the
risk and they're even
this week i've experienced that just
like on a parenting level you know
sometimes the things that you watch
other people do and and um like your
kids whenever they're going out for
something that they love and and it's
easier sometimes to respond to be like
let's just not do that and save yourself
the pain you know what i mean of
possible rejection or
um
but then i remember that god is so much
more concerned about our journey than he
is our destination he is so much more a
god who is with us
walking the journey with us
and not as concerned about the end goal
you know like we can be so end goal
focused that we forget about what we're
learning and how we're growing and how
he's changing us the work that he's
doing in our lives and sometimes we're
just called to trust him and continue
stay the course like those are the words
that keep going through my head like
stay the course
be faithful with what i've given you and
trust me
i am with you
so i hope that as we sing this together
as you guys um meditate on these words
and sing them out i hope that that
prayer can be one that resonates inside
of all of us
god be with me you are with me i will
stay the course i will be faithful and i
will trust you to do the same
[Music]
you call me out upon the waters
the great unknown
and there i find you in the mystery
in ocean's deep
faith will stand
and i will call upon your name
[Music]
and keep my eyes above the waves
when oceans arise my soul
rests in your embrace
cause i
am
and you are
[Music]
will be
surrounds me
never
failed and
[Music]
and keep my eyes above the
ways when oceans arise my soul will rest
in your embrace
for i
am
and you
are
[Music]
mine
me where my trust is without borders let
me walk upon the waters
wherever you would call me
and take me deeper than my feet could
ever wander
and my faith would be made stronger
in the presence of my savior
spirit lead me where my trust
let is walk upon the waters
[Music]
lead me where my trust is
wonder
my faith
wow
[Music]
and i will call upon your name
i'll keep my eyes above the
waves
when oceans rise my soul will rest in
your embrace
foreign
[Music]
hey
you were mine
[Music]
we belong to you
we're going to do the prayers of the
people now and if you're joining us
online feel free to leave
whatever you're carrying tonight in the
comments and we will share those
with the room and um
would you guys read this prayer aloud
with me
for the city of saxi texas and for every
city and community and all of those who
live in them
we pray to you
for the good earth that you have given
us
and the wisdom and the will to conserve
it
we pray to you
for those who travel on land sea or air
for the old and the sick for the widow
and the orphan
for the injured and the suffering we
pray to you
for the poor and oppressed the
unemployed and destitute for prisoners
and captives and for all who remember
and care for them
we pray to you
lord we know that you love us
and that you hear us and so now we lift
these names and situations up to you
for the names and moments that we've
spoken aloud and for those that we have
kept in our hearts we pray to you that
they may have life and light
healing and hope
peace
and a deep sense of your presence
amen
[Music]
you
make his face shine upon you and be
gracious to you
lord
[Music]
amen
um
[Music]
the lord bless you
and
keep you
make his face shine upon you and be
gracious
[Music]
love
me
[Music]
um
may his favor be upon
[Music]
his favor be upon
in the evening and you're coming and
you're going you're waving and rejoicing
he's for you he's for you
you he's for you he is for you
[Music]
oh
me
[Music]
these presents
he is
[Music]
he's for you
he's for you he's for you
[Music]
um
me
[Music]
scott every time we sing those words
together
we the cry of our heart is saying may it
be so
may you go before us
and beside us
may you be all around us may we find you
within us even in the places that feel
dark and alone would we find you there
would we find your presence in the pit
and on the mountaintop no matter where
we go no matter what we've done you are
the one
who steadies us
you are the one who anchors us
you are the one who finds us in the muck
and the mire and pulls us up and sets
our feet on a rock because you don't
lose hope and you don't lose faith and
you don't lose belief
god you are the all-sustaining
all-redeeming all-knowing one
and we look to you tonight
and we ask you god help us to see
ourselves the way that you do
help us to love others the way that you
have
god when when we're singing those words
about
his favor
being on us a thousand generations and
your family and your children and your
children i couldn't help but
feel this burden that some of us it's
hard to say those words because
it's hard to speak blessing over
families when some of us have
experienced so much pain in that area
but in faith i believe that we can take
some of the shame and some of the pain
that has surrounded that
and turn it into good
and speak blessing forward and say here
on out i will be a person who blesses
others i will be a person who believes
for others i will be a safe place
for my kids or from my siblings or for
my parents
i will change the way that things have
been going
and it will start with me
god would you use us
not to return evil for evil but to
return evil with good
would we be a people who speak out
blessing
who believe when it's so hard
even through our pain
even through shame
would we trust you to keep doing your
good work
and defined beauty
rising up from the ashes
[Music]
you are the miracle worker
the promise keeper
the light in our darkness
and we trust you to do that work god
and we will stay the course
we will stay the course
we love you
thank you for your faithfulness and your
love
in your name we pray all these things
amen
you guys can go ahead and sit down and
welcome the people around you as you do
make them feel at home we're so glad
you're all here
all right good evening
grace and peace my name is brett
i'm the pastor here and
it is really really good to be
with all of you i'm so grateful and as
always that includes um those joining us
online
and um as well as anyone here who is new
this is maybe your you know first second
third fourth time there's just kind of
maybe you're just finding your way into
the community we're um just really
really glad that you're that you're with
us tonight
so um
we are in a series right now it's called
first peter part four
and uh
we have this week and next week
and then we are done with the book of
first peter
um so the the title of my message um
tonight is anxiety and identity
anxiety and identity um and i want to
kind of tie these together this is um in
a lot of ways
this is uh i don't know anyone relate to
the anxiety theme tonight any maybe a
few of you of us yeah
yeah
um
it's very prevalent actually i want to
unpack this um a lot more
in ways this week's message is tied in
with last week's
not in a way where you won't understand
this weeks if you weren't here but
basically last week we were talking
about um humility and we we're pretty uh
or i tried to name that humility isn't
um just putting yourself down you know
just like oh i'm just a nobody you know
in the sight of god or something it's
like a sort of weird thing um no it said
humility is just the grace of you being
you um and so which means pride
is um kind of a certain falseness it's
like we see it even with the word
pretentious you know when you kind of
try to inflate your sense of self try to
be more than we actually are um and
and so what i kind of see there is at
the same root of insecurity that can
kind of just towards at times it kind of
manifests or grows as a sort of weird
you know i'm awesome in every way i'm
perfect my family is perfect
everything's great all the time you know
it sort of comes across as a certain
arrogance um that that same the root of
insecurity from which that grows is also
the same route that our anxiety springs
from which is why i think they're so
closely connected versus five and six
you have been talking about humility um
and then verse seven goes right into
anxiety so tonight obviously um we're
going to be in
verse 7.
first peter chapter 5 verse 7 which says
this cast all your anxiety on him that
would be god because he cares for you
a very famous verse some people
uh maybe have it like pinned on their
little bathroom mirrors
if anyone does that anymore that used to
be a thing and christians in like the
90s and early 2000s you remember the
little little sticky note you know your
your verse like yes
okay caleb had his family had many of
them
yeah not just the bat not just the
bathroom he had them everywhere
um
and um
so where i want to actually start uh
here
so our i'm thinking like generations
back you know um
maybe thousands and thousands of years
ago are like ancestors um they in many
ways like you are here today
because at some point like you're way
back great great great great great great
great you know they were um anxious
they were like um in essence they were
you can think of it as like they were
kind of very tuned into their
environment
uh whether it was like the snapping of a
twig unusually
in the forest
you know whether it was like a shift in
smell on the wind you know it was like
they're just tuned in to nature in their
environment and they knew when something
was up and um this is this this kind of
um
fear this kind of living in fear you
know there's a lot of worries they had
worries about um the basics you know
food
shelter
community clean water uh like all the
basics and um
this was something they were very
worried about and in essence you can
think of human beings today are so um
prone to anxiety because of the
environment from which we came you know
it's a dangerous a dangerous world out
there you know so they're really tuned
in um now this is uh leads us to
something that uh psychologists they
call it in different terms but this is
what we would call basic anxiety so
basic anxiety is basically the worry of
having enough
you know whether it's the food or
shelter or
community and connection or whatever um
there is a show i've been digging
recently that has a lot of basic anxiety
in it it's the show alone
the reality show has anyone seen this
show i'm on the show kick because last
week i talked about shit's creek and
this week it's alone
um
so
uh
alone is a fact so it's like you know
reality television thing and basically
the the whole premise is for those
unfamiliar like a dozen or so
contestants are just launched out into
the wilderness
um
but they literally have to do like their
own camera work
um so it's not like you know sort of be
fake alone if it's like you launched out
there but you kind of know well there's
a camera crew following them around you
know but on this show they're literally
it's like the dozen or so contestants
are spread over like a hundred square
miles they don't even interact with each
other they are alone
and i mean it's fascinating um
all of the things that can go wrong i
found it so hard to predict who will win
so hard because like you'll have like i
remember there's this one guy um i mean
i'm thinking oh
he's gonna he's gonna be amazing at this
because it's basically just last as long
as you can and they intentionally the
producers like they frame it to where
winter winter is coming different show
but right so where they because probably
because these folks could like they're
so good at what they do if you just put
them in like tahiti well they just live
out there for 30 years you know like
they're fine so it has to be cold so
it's like a lot of times canada at you
know in the late fall so it just forces
this kind of crisis but
early on i thought oh i can predict i
think you know so i saw this one guy he
was like been in the military literally
training people like and how to like
basically a wilderness expert
training other people in the military
how to survive the wilderness that was
his job for like 15 years i was like oh
bro this guy's lived outside he's gonna
win you know what like just got him it
was actually the aloneness there was
this moment where he had brought a
picture of his family
and that that was the end like three he
actually had like salmon stacked up for
weeks
but he's looking at his family he's like
i'm just worried for them
and i'm feeling so i like it just got to
him
the aloneness there's another moment
where there's a woman and you're like
she hasn't eaten in like a week
and she's trying to catch fish they're
not swimming into her gill net learned
that term from that show never heard of
a gill net
i'm pretty sure i can build a good gill
net now
not really um
but you watch as like she's just not
catching fish i mean i'm like watching
the show feeling anxiety for her i'm
like we gotta catch a fish you know um
another moment maybe the most intense
that i've seen there's a guy you see him
he's whittling a wooden spear
in his his tent his lean to hut with
sticks
and literally he's surrounded by a wolf
pack they're howling he's like
well i can't get all these but the first
one that comes through that door by door
he means his five sticks put together
i'm gonna get it i'm just like like talk
about basic anxiety
that show
now here's what's interesting
um
most of us i'm presuming don't live like
that
right like we have a lot of food in the
pantry you know our problem is not like
too few calories if anything it's sort
of like okay i've got stop this food is
so delicious all this magic food we have
nowadays cheetos oh my gosh i love
cheetos they're so good
uh
it or you think um
like obviously uh shelter you know maybe
we don't have like the nicest of houses
maybe it's not our dream home whatever
but like can we probably most of you
have a a place
um so it's it's interesting that so much
has changed kind of in our world um and
so you might think like oh okay
well geez we should just all relax
like we should
we shouldn't be anxious at all what do i
have to worry about i got food for like
three months in my pantry
got a roof got you know like
everything's fine so you might think oh
good uh anxiety has been eradicated from
the modern world but as all of those
hands showed us um earlier at the very
end the message uh that is not at all
the case which sort of begs the question
what is up
you know like and i don't mean that in a
shaming way like come on guys get over
it you know but but i mean in a legit
question like
yeah why is that like okay because i'm
thinking of my great great grandparents
they'd be like brett you're set because
i do struggle pretty bad anxiety um
they'd be the brit you're set you got
food you got all the clean drinking
water you could hope for you know it's
like well
so um
there's a psychologist out of abilene
christian university um his name is
richard beck he's written some wonderful
books um and he talks about this and he
says well there's two types of anxieties
there's basic anxiety this worry about
having enough he says but there is
another type of anxiety
and it's it's so basic anxiety is a
worry of having enough
neurotic anxiety is the worry of
being
enough
being enough in other words
um it's a it's it's very it's a social
anxiety
how am i measuring up to others
how do i feel in this interaction
are they judging me i think they're
judging me
you know it's it's all of those fears
it's in other words this is why i titled
it anxiety and identity
because this is where they're so deeply
intertwined
for example there have been some
studies done that have shown
that our own kind of sense of like
self-esteem and such our own sense of
kind of doing well in life versus doing
poorly and the more poorly we feel like
we're doing the more anxiety we can have
that that has been shown
that um it's not so much as simple as
just like how much money you make
at least when it comes to neurotic
anxiety instead it's really how much
money you tend to make in comparison to
the people in your friend group
or
like in your social circles does that
make sense so in other words unlike for
example this is even holds true with
like housing and you know cars and
things like if if you live let's say you
live like in a big like a huge house
something your great great great
grandparents would have been like oh my
gosh you live in a mansion you know
let's just say like 4 000 square feet
dream home just this huge home more than
you could ever need but
the research says that if you live in a
neighborhood where the houses
are like way more than that ten thousand
fifteen thousand square foot mansions
how will you feel
you'll feel poor
you'll feel like i'm just
i'm trying i'm trying
but it's like i just can't get ahead i
can't i don't feel good i i feel anxious
i don't feel successful
i don't feel like i'm killing it you
know i just feel like a failure
but can you see how it's it's like it's
relative
um
we had a um
a really cool moment this was
a few weeks ago we had our summer rama
kind of kids event
some of you know about this it was sort
of our equivalent of vbs
and it was a week and we kind of had all
the chairs out here we had like 30 kids
you know running around and doing their
their thing but our theme for that
weekend um was masterpiece
and the idea was
that each each kiddo
is god's masterpiece
made in god's image
fully loved fully accepted
just as they are
and um
there was something so
um
so beautiful
about we had this i mean for one just
the theme and just seeing kids like
at least those moments where they were
listening
you know like were they you could just
kind of see it like sinking in you know
and we had this one little sweet moment
where
when the leaders
led the children in this this old sunday
school song at least that's where i know
it from maybe it's been a long time
since you've sung this one there's
something so almost magical about
hearing um 30 kids
sing
jesus loves me this i know
for the bible tells me so
little ones do him be long
they are weak but he is strong
yes jesus loves me
the bible
tells me so
there's something so
simple
and yet so profound about those words
i was thinking you know at the end of
all of our
questions
after we've
many of us have had such a journey of
trying to let go of destructive
theologies and ideas about god and what
he allegedly thinks about me and that
were really negative and tore
tore us down
said we weren't you know measuring up
um
after we've been through that process
after we've done all of the
deconstructing
that we can like possibly do
um
may the whole
journey
in the point
the end goal of it all be at least this
is my prayer
may it be not to just exit the faith
um
but may it be a journey
to come back to its
heartbeat
to kind of peel away
all of the crap and the lies
and and to recover their like a little
beating heart
which i think would be something like
that song
or maybe something like the beginning of
john 3 16 for god so loved
the world
that he gave
his son
christ
came among us lived among us
for
everything that our sin our
shame our
fear
our anxiety
we're all on the cross
rose again
offers us
new life
resurrection life a fresh start
a new identity
and an identity
where i don't have to
perform
and try to earn
my sense of self
and just sort of fight my way through
the anxiety and just become a somebody
but instead
i receive it
i might sum it up like this to be
christian is not to secure my identity
as beloved through anxious striving but
to receive my belovedness as
a gift
let me say that one more time to be
christian
is not to secure my identity in other
words my sense of self that i'm good
enough that i'm valuable that i'm worthy
that i'm lovable that i'm acceptable
it's it's not to like fight for that and
like prove it to the world but it's it's
we don't have to do it in that anxious
way it's actually to receive it
to receive a sense of our own
belovedness our own worthiness of being
loved
as
a gift
i think this is the the good news
of um
what we call what the with the old
language would be the gospel
i think this is i think this is the the
heartbeat
of the gospel
that god became human
so that um we could
become divine so we could enter into
union with god not that we like in a
weird megalomaniacal way of like i'm god
you know but in a in a sense of deep
intimacy in connection
with god that transforms our identity
that transforms our sense of self
where i just i know that i know that i
know that i know that i'm loved
and if i have one prayer for this
community like
that's it i just want every person to
know like know that you know that you
know that you know that you're loved and
not just by me or by the people around
you though that is very important
because it's a powerful conduit through
which god's love reaches us but
ultimately
people will let you down i'll just be
honest it's an imperfect love
you know um
but
by
the one who made you
by the god who is father son holy spirit
by the one who is loving relationship um
herself
that there's there's such a such a
powerful
um transformative love that can fill you
and
allow you to live in a relaxed way
where you can be both humble and start
to learn
to be a little bit more non-anxious
uh the catholic spiritual writer
spiritual writer henry now and he put it
this way he said over the years
i've come to realize that the greatest
trap in our life
is not success popularity or power
but self-rejection
when we have come to believe in the
voices that call us worthless and
unlovable
then success popularity and power are
easily perceived as attractive
solutions
i think that's incredibly insightful
because i think even preachers can do a
lot of preaching against you know
popularity of success by like hey don't
chase those things stop it stop it stop
you know it's sort of don't it's almost
the the whole um like i think talking
about you know our own
failures and struggles and sins and
things can be good
but another level kind of constantly
harping on you know sinfulness years
center and you need to change your ways
you know i think it can be a little bit
counterproductive in a way because at
its root what's going on
um it's often comes back to identity
you know like i can look at someone
who's like chasing power or chasing
success and i can be like you shouldn't
do that you know that's gonna lead you
to a bad end or like
you know you won't love yourself or your
life or
but to see a little bit deeper and
realize why are they doing that
why
it's it's
it's us right it's our own hearts
it's about becoming
at ease with who god's actually made us
to be
self acceptance
so coming back to first peter 5 7 when
it says cast all your anxiety on him
because he cares for you i think one way
to read that in a common way it's
preached though i haven't really
preached it quite like that tonight
is the idea of basic anxiety right the
the idea there would be um there's no
worry so small that god doesn't care
about it there's no worry so big that
he's like overwhelmed like no god's got
it and maybe for some of you you're like
honestly i didn't really need the
neurotic anxiety message i needed like
the basic anxiety you know if that's you
well then let this be your moment this
is god's word to you like he's got your
basic anxiety like he can handle it that
guy's not overwhelmed not thrown off
like and it's if it's too heavy for you
to carry
do your best to just let it go give it
to god god's got it but
um
there's another way to read that passage
and it's through the lens of neurotic
anxiety
which
maybe a way to think of it would be when
it says cast all your anxiety on him
because he cares for you it could be to
say
cast all those old
playing through your head again and
again and again on like some sort of
sick repeat it just keeps going
relentlessly often it's because there
were people in our life often like some
sort of authority figure maybe a parent
or a grandparent or a teacher or a coach
or someone
who they themselves were not in a good
place
and so they they spoke lies over you
um these lies that like you're a failure
the lie that that you're some sort of
screw-up you never do anything right
no one likes you no one sees you
no one values you you're not doing
enough you're not measuring up i just
want to name it clearly tonight those
are
lies as my mother would say
those are lies from the pit of hell
that's what she said when i was little
it's a very intense saying
but sometimes it's absolutely true
those are those are lies
lies in the pitiful this is it is the
those are antichrists
those are the opposite
of the word christ speaks over you
because the word christ speaks over you
is you are accepted
you are accepted some some of you need
to hear that tonight
you are accepted
just as you are
god sees you god knows you god loves you
you are accepted
and for many of us it's um
it's a journey
as minnie was talking about earlier it's
a journey to
embrace that isn't it
um
but but a necessary one so in closing i
want to um get a little bit practical
um because i think it would be easy to
be like you know
maybe some of you are thinking like well
good speech
how do i be less anxious you know
how do i receive that and of course
that's a complicated you know that's
like
the journey of a lifetime
living in all that so i won't try to
boil everything down into one you know
point or something but i do want to give
you some sort of handhold and i'll give
you a little bit of how i've been
practicing
um casting my anxiety anxiety on god um
so each morning i wake up a little bit
earlier than my kids
because every parent needs coffee before
their children wake up
and so i wake up and make coffee and
then i grab the scriptures and i read a
few pages
and if you get my my e letter then you
know we just kind of keep making our way
through the book and that's just my
daily bible reading i just keep sending
out whatever i've read that's what you
get
um so i'm in mark right now um i read
the scriptures
i say some prayers for um
myself my family
you
um others people going through things
you know
and then i do one last very important
thing and i started this eight years ago
when my professor gave us a challenge
now he put a time kind of
goal on it or whatever and i won't do
that with you um but he said uh i
challenge you he said no one will do
this which is probably he's just doing a
psychological thing you know all the
achievers in the room are like oh you
said no we'll do this i'll do it it
worked on me here i am eight years later
i've been doing it um
but he said he said i challenge you take
30 minutes
a day for
quiet
don't do a thing
just sit quietly he said no one will do
it
um i must admit i
cannot always do 30 minutes
but i have found this to be an
incredibly
powerful
practice
partly because modern society
it just prevents silence we always have
our
phones we're getting into some of this
next week actually um
always goes we're just always buzzing
and ringing and communicating and and
often it's a way to escape our anxiety
you know we don't quite feel so good in
here so let's do something anything you
know and um
and so what i found is all sit
and maybe for some of you if you've
never done this before then you probably
have the wrong idea you think oh wow
that sounds wonderful oh but it's just
so peaceful you and god
um
not not often um instead what often
comes up i sit there
and then
my neurotic anxiety flares up
i start thinking
i'm like oh my gosh
i got those folks fighting in the church
oh
how are we going to work that out you
know i just whatever like just things of
my kids why don't they just do their
homework i look i look like a terrible
parent you know just
it's like a hundred different things and
just and and but here's the practice
all that stuff comes up
and then i catch myself doing it
i'm replaying the tapes again
and the practice is
i just
give it to god
i have a word a sacred word it's um for
me it's abide
kind of back to jesus you know abide in
me and such from john
um abide and i just take that moment to
just
come back to god
and then i'll have like these little
moments of stillness sometimes it's like
five seconds
sometimes a little longer eight
you know seconds um
i know i'm joking but um
but what happens is i was thinking
actually as i was writing the message
this week i thought huh i never thought
of that as a practice of
what
cast all your anxiety on him
because he cares for you
and so if you're looking for something
tangible practical
um i would encourage you to give that a
try
start finding some silence and stillness
not because it will instantly eradicate
your anxiety um but because it will
start giving you handles
um for how to deal with it how to work
through how to give it back to god
because honestly it's for him to carry
he's got it
so as we
come to the table of the lord tonight
i want this to be uh
maybe a moment where you're able to
let something go you know we often come
through those these doors
carrying heavy burdens
um maybe it's health
maybe it's
career
or the lack thereof maybe it's it's
something with kids you know it's
different for every person but i want to
encourage you to do this as you come
forward tonight to partake of communion
um
i wouldn't encourage you to let
something
go
just give it back to god
you might even say just god this is too
heavy for me to carry
i'm giving it to you
so as we protect the bread um
representing the body of christ and the
the wine
representing his blood
may this be a moment of re-centering may
it be a little moment to unburden
yourself tonight
so um instructions for how to take
communion will be on the screen
and i want to invite you to the table
with these words this is the table
not of the church
but of the lord
and it's made ready for those who love
him and for those who want to love him
more so come
you who have much faith
and you who have little
you who have been here often and you who
have not been here long
you who have tried to follow
and you who have failed
come
because it's the lord who invites you
and it's his will that those who want to
meet him should meet him here
come to the table
so
[Music]
let's see
is
do
so
you guys are welcome to just stay seated
during this last song if you'd like to
and just
listen to it as jesse sings
this song has been so meaningful to me
and i was remembering um in our planning
call this week that the first time i
heard this song was actually when
um we were kind of in the process of
figuring out if the table was going to
be its own thing and and that was a
really emotionally charged season um
and and there was a lot of pushback and
it was one of those times that i look
back on and i remember
kind of um
what god impressed on me
during that time more than anything
probably was just that
you know sometimes you are going to come
up against resistance
he hasn't promised us a perfect path
um
and just because we're following him
doesn't mean that it will be easy or
that
it will always go smoothly but
he does promise to be with us
in the journey just like we were talking
about earlier and as god's doing this
work in us with our anxiety or whatever
it is that you're facing in yourself
that you know like this is something god
has his finger on like
gotta keep going here we gotta keep
doing the work you know maybe it's just
something that you personally want help
with i just want this song to be an
encouragement to you tonight um stay the
course he is with you in the journey he
will do a good work in you
um
even when it's not easy so
there is
[Music]
don't let the darkness
surround you
can make it through
don't you give up
on the kingdom
[Music]
think it's crashing in
knowing worth all the worry
[Music]
they'll still let you in
some
days
[Music]
sometimes the way
of decisions
[Music]
don't let the shame
tell you something
[Music]
that you know
just cause you feel
like a stranger
that don't mean you are
god i could
use a reminder
[Music]
of what forgiveness is for
someday soon
[Music]
some
days
[Music]
sometimes
just cause they say
some
days
[Music]
so
worries
[Music]
don't think
sometimes
don't think the best
[Music]
these worries
soon
[Music]
some
these days
[Music]
uh thank you worship dane that was
and
there's something sometimes where i'm
listening to brett and i'm like
that message is for me
that's what those today was one of those
days
uh just a quick reminder
um i'm gonna be in the back um because
i would love to
sit and pray if you need prayer i'd love
to give you a hug if that's something
you need a high five or just some sort
of pointing connection because i would
hate for you just to walk out of the
store without being seen
or have experience that somebody here
cares about you
um the other thing is that um
for visitors and we love that we have
visitors that come to us we want also
want to acknowledge that you're here
there are some cards in the very back as
you walk out the door if you wouldn't
mind just taking one just kind of
filling out
so we just have it acknowledge that
you're here and we just have record and
we just also want to say thank you that
you're here
and if you once it's our ministry you
can also do
that by either there's a box in the back
where you can either give your donation
in the back or you can do that also
online
and before we go leave i want to send
you out with this blessing
so if you don't mind standing
especially with
the anxiety conversation i think these
words are very very true
so you are a child of god
you
are a child of god
and this is true on your best day
and it's true on your worst day
so as you go into your weeks ahead with
this yet to determine highs and lows and
everything in between
go
filled with the assurance that you are
loved
you are worthy
and you are accepted
just as you are
and go filled with god's holy spirit and
the desire to extend these same gifts of
grace and unconditional love with
everyone you come in contact with
thank you guys have a great week
[Music]
sometimes
is
[Music]
worries
days
[Music]